Or the age of seven,
and Helen Keller was described by family members as a little monster.
She threw temper tantrums,
attacked,
meant a terrible personal habits.
Yet within a year,
the deaf and blind girl had been transformed.
She became teachable.
That teaching on top to level of genius and determination which saw her overcome
her disability and achieve unimaginable success.
In this week's biographics,
we explore how Helen Keller beat incredible odds to become a true inspiration to
the world.
Helen Keller was born on June the 27th,
18,
80 in Tuscumbia,
a small town in northern Alabama.
She was a perfectly healthy baby with the ability to see and hear how mother
Kate's just 23 years old was the pampered southern Belle who doted on her first
child's.
Helen's father,
author,
Ray,
confederate veteran of the civil war was 42 when his daughter was born.
Case was his second wife and he had two grown sons from his first marriage.
The birth of Helen was a relief to Katie and now had a child of our own to
shower love and attention.
Upon Alan was it quick developer speaking her first words at six months and
taking her first steps on a fest birthday.
However,
in February 18,
82 at the age of 19 months,
she became severely ill with what doctors at the time called brain fever.
Modern researchers believed that she may have had scarlet fever or possibly
meningitis,
whatever the cause of her illness.
The local doctor was convinced that the child would not survive.
Alan did survive,
but the illness have rubbed.
Our river herring and test site have bright happy world was now filled with
silence and darkness as an adult Helen records coming out of her illness.
I was too young to realize what happens when I awoke and found that it was dark
and still I suppose I thought it was nice and I must have wondered why David was
so long coming gradually,
however,
I got used to the silence and darkness that surrounded me and forgot that it had
ever been day for the first few months after her illness,
a terrified helen would do no more than sit in their mother's lap and kings who
are dressed as kate tried to do her daily chores.
Then she began to venture out on their own,
first crawling around the room and feeling her way forward.
She discovered that her hands could in a small way,
do the job of our eyes helping her to identify objects and different areas of
the house with Kate's patient assistance.
Helen also developed a crude system of communication,
a shake of the head for no one's and nod for yes,
I pull on her mother's dress for come before long,
she had incorporated pantomime actions.
And do you have vocabulary?
If she wanted ice cream,
she would pretend she was working the freezer aisle while shivering.
However,
attentive mother would then rushed to give her whatever she wants it.
Helen proved to be very determined.
Child,
if she sets her mind on the task,
she would keep at this until she wants successful.
At greatest desire was to improve our ability to communicate with others,
making simple signs with our hands was simply not enough.
Perhaps the inability to people understand what she was thinking and feeling led
to a level of frustration,
but wells deep insight up this lead to violent outbursts of temper,
including screaming fits and even violence.
Al bests.
Helen's temper tantrums.
They terrorize the family.
She would smash landon's thrust her fist in plates of food and pinch whoever was
close by.
Relatives referred to the child as a monster and strongly urged and offer to put
her into an institution.
In 18,
85,
kate had a second child,
mildred baby sister for Helen with my mother's doting attention now being
shared,
Helen became intensely jealous.
Ones she knocked over mildred's,
caught causing the baby to fall out.
Desperate case was an absolute wit's ends,
unable to control or help helen anymore.
However,
she remains determines not to send her away.
When Helen was six,
I father learned of a doctor in Baltimore,
Maryland's named Julian Krystle.
He would help to restore sight to blind people.
The family took the trip to consult with Dr Chris on only to be told that there
was nothing medically that can be done to fix helen's eyesight,
but the doctor did hold out a ray of hope.
He told the colors of autumn man,
who specialized in helping deaf children to communicate his name.
It was Alexander Graham Bell,
although today he is best remembered as the inventor of the telephone.
Bells.
Passion was actually helping the death.
Belle's mother and wife.
We're both death.
In fact,
he had met his wife,
Mabel when he had taken on the job.
Let's have private tutor teaching her through a system of signing that he had
developed the Kellers.
It decided to travel to Washington in order to meet him.
Helen felt comfortable with belt right away,
but that first meeting,
he sat her on his knee and his handler,
his pocket watch.
She was delighted with the vibrations that she felt when the watch struck.
The our bell suggested the Kennedys ranked to the Perkins Institute for the
Blind in Boston requesting a tutor for Helen,
the institute that trains teachers so you could go out and work with deaf and
blind students.
The director of the institute looked over the list of recent graduates settling
upon his star pupil,
a 20 year old who was herself partially blind from suffering Tacoma as a child.
Her name was Anne Sullivan
and Sullivan arrived at the Keller House on March the third,
18,
87.
Helen's stood in the doorway as she approached the child,
knew you from her mother's scurried activities that morning,
but something important was happening,
but she didn't yet know what the most important day I remember in all my life is
the one in which my teacher and Mansfield Sullivan came to me.
Helen could hear footsteps approaching,
assuming it was a mother.
She held her hand and took the girl's hand and pulls her in for an embrace,
but when Helen realized that this was a stranger,
she struggled to break free.
This was the first of many temper outbursts that and would be confronted with.
The very next day in a fit of rage,
the students knocked out one of our teachers from Tif,
but Helen was quick to realize the Miss Sullivan was not about to let the
petulant child get away with outrageous behavior,
hasn't been happening up until then when the breakfast table and hadn't reached
across to grab food from Anz plate that she was accustomed to doing with family
members and grabs her hands and pushed it away.
This scent Helen,
into a fit of she flopped on the floor and exhibits exhibitors a full on
Tantrum.
Sullivan asked the other family members to leave the room and lock the door.
She then proceeded to continue eating her breakfast,
completely ignoring Holland's performance.
Finally,
the exasperated child got off the floor and felt friend's body to see what she
was doing.
Why want you to discover that and was commonly eating her food.
She again began to grab the plates at each time and would slap her hand away.
Helen then began pinching ans hand something that she was allowed to do with
impunity to our family members again,
and slap the hand away.
Finally,
hello.
Sat back on her chair and began eating her food and she seen came to the
realization that Helen's family members had been enabling her behavior.
She knew that's made any progress.
She would have to separate the child from her parents.
The kellers agreed to let Anne and Helen lived in a small cottage not far from
the main house and wanted Helen to things that they had traveled a long distance
from the family,
so the two of them set out on a carriage ride.
This unknown to Helen circled back to the cottage.
Helen wasn't happy to be packed off with a strict new teacher.
She spent the first day screaming and throwing things around the cottage that
night and have a hotel and down for hours just to keep her in best.
The child's strength and determination.
They were incredible,
but I'm was just that little bit greater as the days and weeks passed and was
able to slowly bring Helen under control.
The change began when Anne started spelling out words on Helen's part.
The first word was doll.
The finger play in tree teller and she proved to be an excellent minute.
Soon she was spelling out a dozen,
three letter words with her fingers,
but she still didn't know what they met.
The breakthrough came on April the fifth,
18,
87 that morning and had been trying to get out and do you understand the
differences between the words,
Mug and water.
She took her to the water pump,
pound,
sign the cottage,
and had the girl hold out a mug and then work to the pump so the water filled it
and began to overflow.
She then began to spell the word water on Helen's free hands.
Suddenly the light went off.
In Helen's mind,
she later wrote that living world awakened my soul.
Give it light,
hope,
joy,
set it free.
Now she had a taste for word meanings.
She couldn't get enough.
She wanted to and to spell out everything around her.
She managed add dozens of new words to have vocabulary every single day as their
understanding of the world group.
Alan's personality began to mellow and the temper tantrums became less frequent.
She came to understand that people would treat her with greater empathy if she
displayed a kind and caring personality with the key to knowledge,
understanding words meaning now unlocked.
Helen was able to learn with amazing speed in just a few short months.
She was reading books in Braille and was no longer at spelling only simple words
onto Helen's pile.
Now she was signing portions of Shakespeare and so the Bible,
by the time she was nine,
Helen was reading the works of such great poets as Shelly longfellow and Oliver
Wendell Holmes.
This made her far more advanced in a literary sense than most other children of
her age,
and quickly came to the realization that Helen's ability to comprehend complex
ideas was highly advanced.
Writing a report to the director of the Perkins School for the blind.
She spoke of vans near genius level learning ability,
but she added the director must not show the report to anyone else she didn't
want to add in to be turned into a prodigy.
However,
the director Michael and saw Helen story isn't opportunity for reflected glory.
He talks all the 56th annual report of the Perkins School,
Helen Keller,
a second,
Laura Bridgeman in the reports in embellished Helen story,
making it even more irresistible to the press before long newspapers all over
the country.
We're writing gushing stories about the child genius.
He was reading Shakespeare despite not being able to see or hear Helen story
even reached across the Europe where Queen Victoria was intrigued.
Do you hear of the brilliant little deaf and blind girl by age 10?
Having color was an internationally renowned figure when a policeman shot her
dog,
lioness.
The news was picked up in the papers.
Indeed people began sending her money to buy another doc.
Helen was reported as saying that she didn't need a new dog,
but she would like to use the money to help a poor blind,
deaf and mute boy named Tommy Stringer to attends the Perkins School for the
blind.
The public responded and Tommy's tuition fees were paid for.
This inspired Helen.
He wants to help more children,
so she began writing letters to people who are willing to donate money
by the time she was 10 years of age.
Helen had not spoken a clear word in her life,
but then in March of 18,
90,
she heard about a deaf blind girl in Norway who had learned to speak with our
mouth.
Now she became obsessed with doing the same thing and Sullivan,
new justice you could help out and that would be Sarah Fuller,
the director of the school for the deaf in Boston,
Massachusetts Fuller decided to teach helen herself.
She took a hold of Helen's hands and placed it over her mouth to allow the girl
to feel the movement of our lips and tongue as she spoke,
helen then copied the motions without own speech organs.
After only an hour of intense concentration and effort,
she was able to speak her first sentence.
It's too warm.
The sounds of Helen's voice,
however,
was almost impossible to understand how untrained vocal chords would need a lot
of practice before she was able to make legible speech.
In later years,
she would train for three summers under the guidance of a famous music teacher
in order to improve her speaking voice back at Alabama.
I learned that and continue to work on speech developments.
They also developed a method of hearing what others were saying.
She would place a thumb on the throat of the speaker,
her forefinger on their lips and her middle finger on their notes.
This would allow her to translate the vibrations into sounds
in November 18,
91,
11 year old helens and the birthday presents and Michael and agnostic director
of the Perkins Institute.
It was a short story that she had written on her Braille slate or the frost
king,
and I was impressed with the quality of the pros and published the story and the
Perkins Alumini magazine.
Helen was overjoyed to become a published author,
but the joy was short lived.
Reports reach Tuscumbia that there was a book in Prince Goals of the frost.
Fairies by Margaret t can be the story was uncannily.
Similar to Helen Story,
the frost gang accusations started to circulate that she had plagiarized the
story.
When this was explained to her,
she was horrified.
Reading can be.
She realized the similarities were striking,
but she was adamant that she had written her own original story.
The reality was that Helen had become a voracious reader.
She would digest one book after another with no thought who had written them.
Ideas became jumbled in her mind,
and she wasn't able to remember if they came from yourself or from what she had
read,
so when she enthusiastically produced a story,
she believed that the ideas own.
However,
a worker at the Parkinson's institute had indeed read the frost ferries to her
for a year before the story simply became lodged in her subconscious and it was
clearly the inspiration for the frost king.
The incident caused deep embarrassment for Helen.
She wrote that down in a diary.
It made us feel so bad that people thought we had been untrue and wicked.
My heart was full of tears for I love the beautiful truth with my whole heart
and mind.
Michael and Agnes was also humiliated by the incidents he had to print a
retraction to explain the mixup off questioning.
Helen,
he believes that no deliberate plagiarism was involved,
but then one of his teachers reported to him that Helen had confessed the
wrongdoings or heart.
The truth was that this manipulative teacher had twisted Helen's words to make
us sound guilty.
It was enough,
however,
an agnostic turn against Helen and his former star pupil and Sullivan.
He sets up a formal hearing in which Helen was interrogated by an eight member
panel.
It was one of the most terrifying experiences if the 11 year old's life.
After a day of tough scrutiny,
the panel was split down the middle as to whether deliberate plagiarism was
involved in the ends and agnostics split stalemates coming down on the side of
Helen.
The Frost King Experience Haunted Helen for many years to come.
Whenever she wrote a sentence from then onwards,
she would check it repeatedly to make sure that it was our own original work.
In March 18,
93 and intelligent attended the presidential inauguration of grover Cleveland's.
From there,
they went to Niagara Falls where Helen was astounded.
It's and it's the power of the vibrations caused by the massive pounding waters.
They then went on to Chicago to attend the world's fat.
They were escorted by Alexander Graham Bell,
who was featuring his telephone at the great exhibition,
but the famous deaf blind gal who had conquered her handicaps was just as much a
draw card as the renowned in Venza,
the exhibition which featured exhibits from all over the world,
frilled Helen.
She was the only one of the millions of visitors.
He was allowed to run her hands over the exhibits.
This gave a a far greater appreciation of the world around than anything she had
read in books whetting our appetite to learn more.
At the age of 16,
Helen began studying.
It became bridge school for young ladies in Cambridge,
Massachusetts.
She was now in class alongside and competing with girls you could see in hip.
I'm Sullivan attended every class alongside Helen interpreting the lessons.
Helen made rapid progress completing her first year study with honors in German
and English in our second year.
However,
she struggled,
especially with mathematics.
The decision was made to withdraw her from the school and provide her with a
private tutor.
A year later,
she was ready to take the entrance exam for Radcliffe College,
the Women's division of Harvard University passing with distinction.
She became the first person with major disabilities to enter an institute of
higher learning.
Helen found the pace at Radcliffe,
frantic again.
She had animal alongside how to spell out the lessons on her fingers,
but even then she had difficulty keeping pace with fast talking lecturers
despite the hurried pace.
How long did well,
especially in English during her second year as a literacy teacher,
encouraged her to write her life story so that the world could get an insight
into the struggles that she had gone through.
Helen worked on the manuscript while studying,
which also placed an intolerable strain on her.
Finally in March of 19.
Oh,
three,
the story of my life was published.
Sales were slow at first,
but it has gone on to become a beloved classic and it was recognized by the New
York public library as one of the 100 most important books of the 20th century.
Indeed,
this was the first of 15 books that she would go on to write.
Helen graduated from Radcliffe on June the 28th,
Nineteen,
Oh,
four.
To become the first person with a serious disability to earn an undergraduate
degree.
She now found herself in demand for speaking engagements where people flocked to
hear her inspirational story in 19 Oh,
five and Sullivan,
Mary John Macy Helps Helen Publish,
have autobiography.
The three of them lived under the same roof with Mason and Helen developing a
very special bond.
Helen devoted the rest of her life to helping the blinds.
She wrote extensively on the subject,
has worked tirelessly for a uniform system of Braille along with them and
sometimes some other case.
She traveled internationally,
giving lectures and sold out halls everywhere from Canada to Australia.
When he died in 1936,
former housemaid poly Thompson became helen's constant companion during World
War Two.
Helen was a ray of hope for the thousands of servicemen who were blinded or
deafened in combat.
During 1943 alone,
she visited 70 army and naval hospitals up and down the United States.
In her later years,
Helen was widely regarded as the greatest living American woman.
In 1964,
she was awarded the Presidential Medal of freedom for years later,
she suffered a heart attack.
She died on June the first 19,
68,
but our home in Westport,
Connecticut,
she was 87 years of age,
so I really hope you enjoyed that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put our brand new videos every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get a notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday.
Won't put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch something else right now,
suffering the archive over there on the race,
and as always,
thank you for watching.